bonjour Clémentine Autain bonjour Merci
d'être invité ce matin débuter la France
insoumise de la 710 au détention pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour on va évidemment parler
longuement de la location d'Emmanuel
Macron vous allez nous dire ce que vous
en avez pensé que les ventilotins le
chef de l'État qui a reconnu qu'à
l'évidence la réforme des retraites n'a
pas été acceptée par les Français il a
admis la colère ça va dans le bon sens
pour vous vous plaisantez franchement
d'ailleurs depuis hier je suis admiratif
de voir le temps passé sur toutes les
antennes à commenter le vide c'est un
exercice qui est pas forcément évident
même si c'est un vide signifiant et vous
aurez remarqué que sur les 13 minutes
d'allocution de président de la
République seul deux minutes ont été
consacrés aux retraites où il a commencé
par nous réexpliquer ce qu'ils
expliquent depuis maintenant deux mois
et demi voire trois mois que la crise
sur les retraites est enclenchée et vous
imaginez bien que c'est pas avec ces
mêmes arguments qu'il va convaincre les
Français qui sont vent debout et il le
sait il n'a pas de légitimité il n'a pas
d'autorité sur ce sujet puisque les
Français ont dit non par tous les biais
ou c'était possible de s'exprimer
démocratiquement il a commencé par les
syndicats les syndicats ont dit non il y
a eu des millions de gens dans la rue et
des enquêtes d'opinion qui les unes
après les autres ont montré que cette
Français sur dix n'en voulait pas et
même 9 actifs sur 10 et enfin à
l'Assemblée nationale comme il n'y avait
pas de majorité qu'elle était
introuvable il a décidé de pas faire le
vote du Parlement de savoir dessus le
Sénat n'est pas l'Assemblée nationale
c'est quand même pas rien pas
l'Assemblée nationale qui ne vote pas
donc il ne tire aucune légitimité
d'aucun des biais démocratiques de ce
pays il avance avec la brutalité avec
l'autorité que lui permet la Cinquième
République parce que c'est ça le
problème dans les commentaires j'entends
beaucoup sa psychologie et c'est vrai
qu'elle est elle est quand même assez
incroyable il n'y a qu'à voir cette
phrase sur les 100 jours on se dit avec
tous les communicants qu'il a autour de
lui toutes les équipes de gens qui ont
fait l'ENA et qui en épargne qui lui dit
écoute les 100 jours c'est grave ça se
termine à Waterloo à Sainte-Hélène
comment est-il possible qu'il est mis
son allocution sous le signe de ces 100
jours c'est délires bon il le fait mais
je pense que au-delà de la psychanalyse
qu'on peut faire éventuellement du
président de la République ou l'analyse
sociologique à faire ben je l'entends
beaucoup et c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'à
un moment donné on se demande parce
qu'il est tellement hors-sol tellement
déconnecté tellement dans un délire de
toute puissance qu'il y a forcément une
dimension psychanalytique mais ce qui
nous intéresse nous c'est comment des
institutions permettent cette situation
normalement nous devrions avoir un
système institutionnel qui empêche un
homme seul de décider contre son peuple
c'est pourquoi nous sommes dans une
crise de régime et je pèse mes mots
c'est un des problèmes c'est que notre
Constitution est trop robuste elle
permet président de la République de
gouverner de alors qu'il a plus la
majorité mais vous savez elle a été
construite par un général pour un autre
contexte
précisément mais ça fait 60 ans qu'elle
est là et au démarrage on était en temps
de guerre c'était la guerre d'Algérie et
il s'agissait pour le général de Gaulle
justement de créer soi-disant la
stabilité et de lui permettre d'avancer
loin de la quatrième où il y avait un
pouvoir
47 ans
totalement construit pour donner tout
pouvoir auprès c'est un régime hyper
présidentiel qui est une anomalie une
anomalie en Europe mais même à travers
le monde aucun régime démocratique nos
confrères un tel pouvoir à un seul homme
et quand il y a pas de majorité ça n'est
pas la minorité qui gouverne on cherche
des coalitions partout dans toutes les
démocraties à travers le monde donc on
est dans une anomalie qui je dirais
aujourd'hui trouve son point d'orgue et
et et devrait maintenant la cinquième
elle devrait être dans la rubrique
nécrologique
l'exécutif aussi à chercher des
coalitions dans la crise à laquelle on
est confronté aujourd'hui il en trouve
pas il en trouve pas mais quand il est
avancé il n'en trouve pas donc la
solution
naturelle ou normale sur la durée de
quoi une une
comment un remaniement un changement de
gouvernement une démission du président
ça commence par ne pas imposer aux
Français de travailler deux ans de plus
alors que le peuple n'y consent pas ça
c'est la base en démocratie donc
oui hier qui je trouve voilà n'est pas
ne fait pas partie de ma famille
politique mais il a dit des choses qui
sont tout à fait juste tout à fait juste
et notamment le fait que le Président de
la République n'a pas d'autorité il n'a
pas d'autorité parce que un des enjeux
forts de la locution d'hier restaurer
aussi l'autorité par par cette prise de
parole n'a pas réussi c'est ce qu'il a
fait au contraire c'est extrêmement
méprisant
un enfant avec des des allumettes dans
une station d'essence et qui s'amuse à à
cotiser alors d'une certaine manière je
pense qu'il contribue à mettre les en
colère et à inviter les Français à
manifester le 1er mai qui va être une
date je pense particulièrement
historique parce que quand vous le
regardez vous dites c'est pas possible
quand est-ce que ça va s'arrêter et donc
il ne va pas calmer la réalisation
qui a été moins il a été moins offensif
que lors de la locution de la terre du
22 mars
on est d'accord alors que par les
précédentes allocution c'est vrai qu'on
avait en prime en prime de la surprise
de de de de discours orwelliens comme on
a eu hier parce qu'ensuite sur le détail
des 100 jours il a enfilé les perles
avec des mots qui sont l'inverse de ce
qui fait enfin je veux dire c'est
orwellien la macronie depuis le depuis
le début la guerre c'est la paix lui
c'est la réforme des retraites c'est la
justice
j'agis par la force et la brutalité
signifie je vous ai compris enfin bon
bref tout ça et tout ça est dingue en
tout cas vous l'avez écoutez vous vous
n'étiez pas tenté par une casserole
mais comme je devais réagir je me suis
dit j'ai quand même je vais quand même
écouter voilà mais de j'étais de tout
cœur avec tous celles et ceux qui
partent en France d'ailleurs se sont
réunis de façon spontanée devant les
mairies avec avec des casseroles et je
suis intriguée de voir l'audiance de
voir l'audience parce que je pense que
le le mot d'ordre de ne pas écouter un
président dont on savait vous avez vu le
son agir 90% des Français disait que ils
pensaient que la locution n'apaiserait
rien et donc quelque part n'attendait
rien de cette allocution et ce mouvement
qui dit on écoute même plus le président
de la République dit cette panne
d'autorité or un président de la
République qui n'a plus d'autorité voyez
le problème c'est que ça veut dire que
il avance sans légitimité sans conduire
le peuple là où il se doit de le
conduire comme homme qui est garant de
l'unité de la nation et là ça soit
dessus et donc les gens ne le
reconnaissent pas s'ils ne veulent pas
l'écouter ça veut dire qu'il ne
reconnaissent pas son autorité à agir
quand on est président de la République
vous voyez le niveau de gravité c'est
pourquoi je pense qu'on est dans une
crise de régime et que la seule solution
Sage d'avenir c'est de modifier notre
système institutionnel pour sortir de
l'hyperprésidentialisme pour donner plus
de pouvoir aux citoyenné aux citoyens
pour faire que le législatif prime sur
l'exécutif pour revoir aussi tout notre
vie
sociale c'est une question uniquement de
constitution ou c'est une de la
personnalité d'Emmanuel Macron qui a
rendu sa possible j'insiste il y a la
personnalité d'Emmanuel Macron mais le
système institutionnel lui permet d'agir
avec cette psychologie et donc je dis
que notre Constitution doit être
revisitée pour empêcher qu'un homme seul
décide contre son peuple c'est pourquoi
nous avons une crise de régime et c'est
pourquoi il faut une sixième république
les 100 jours ça sous-entend que
Elisabeth borde est reconduite à
Matignon au moins pendant ces 100 jours
vous le regrettez je pense que c'est pas
le sujet majeur je veux dire on mettrait
quelqu'un d'autre à la place d'Elisabeth
borne mais pour continuer d'imposer la
réforme des retraites pour continuer la
même politique pour ne rien changer sur
le plan institutionnel écouter ça change
quoi pour les Français rien donc c'est
pas le problème du nom du premier
ministre de la première ministre
problème c'est le cap politique et le
pouvoir du Président de la République
qui écrase la majorité sur la réforme
des retraites il est revenu très
rapidement sur la promulgation ça a été
une de ses premières phrases le Conseil
constitutionnel a validé la loi je l'ai
donc logiquement qu'avez-vous pensé de
cette phrase et je pense que il y a
toujours cette confusion entre la
légalité d'une part et la démocratie les
deux ne se superposent pas et c'est je
trouve la démonstration qui est faite à
travers cette crise c'est à dire que il
peut avoir les outils légaux qui lui
permettent de d'imposer cette loi mais
il n'a pas de légitimité et c'est pour
ça c'est pourquoi ça ne va pas c'est à
dire que le Conseil constitutionnel bon
vous le savez le droit c'est pas une
matière c'est pas une science exacte
c'est une matière d'interprétation donc
le Conseil constitutionnel avait matière
à ne pas la promulguer à ne pas la
valider ce qui je pense aurait été une
décision sage parce qu'elle aurait été
de nature à calmer dans le pays de
décision politique forcément puisque
puisque la matière juridique n'est pas
n'est pas une science et que vous avez
l'interprétation et qu'il décide de la
valider il faut un choix qui me
semble-t-il les deux natures et de
nature politique après tout on peut
aussi se dire que ils ont trouvé dans
les la Constitution matière à la valider
d'où toujours j'y reviens le problème de
cette de cette constitution ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui la bataille politique est
perdue pour vous sur la réforme
et je vois les syndicats très remontés
depuis hier j'ai écouté aussi bien
Laurent Berger que que Sophie Binet de
la CGT qui était remarquable hier et et
honnêtement ils sont
estomacés comme les Français d'ailleurs
il y a une forme de sidération devant ce
président de la République qui n'entend
rien qui enfile les perles qui
continuent à sarcouter comme s'il était
dans un une bulle à part on a
l'impression qu'il qu'il a pas du tout
atterri qui vit pas avec nous qu'il est
qu'il est hors le monde mais c'est grave
pour celui qui est censé encore une fois
nous gouverner et avoir l'autorité de
nous amener au plus haut alors la suite
c'est quoi sur le plan politique et
législatif est-ce que vous allez vous
allez vous associer aux parties
socialiste qui qui va déposer une
proposition de loi pour abroger les 64
ans la question que nous posons ou
peut-être déposer cette proposition de
loi donc dans les deux dans les deux
Olivier Ford dit dans les deux chambres
oui dans les deux chambres mais à quelle
date etc donc la discussion voilà la
discussion n'est pas close sur
l'opportunité de la signer pour ce qui
concerne mon groupe et de voir comment
on peut on peut la déposer mais c'est
une discussion quelle est la je vous dis
la discussion c'est bien maîtriser où
est-ce qu'on va la déposer ensemble
est-ce qu'elle a une chance d'arriver
là pour l'instant on travaille comme
vous le savez aussi sur une motion de
censure
les indépendants
vous savez que la dernière fois elle a
échoué à 9 voix un certain nombre de
républicains l'avaient voté en se disant
qu'il y avait vous savez toutes ces
carottes
derrière le bâton des 64 ans donc
disparu d'ailleurs c'était quand même un
jeu de dupe c'est carottes puisque la
lettre du Conseil d'État qui datait
d'avant les promesses et d'avant les
cavaliers législatifs disaient
clairement que il ne serait validé par
le Conseil constitutionnel donc il y a
eu vraiment une entourloupe
comment comment comme c'est dit dans le
vous savez c'est erroné ce terme erroné
mais le Conseil constitutionnel a décidé
que ce n'est pas grave que les ministres
pouvaient mentir il y a eu un droit un
droit mensonge d'une certaine manière
octroyée par le Conseil constitutionnel
qui dit après ça a été complètement
non mais enfin je veux dire c'est quand
même grave on prend des procédures
inhabituelles c'est pas grave allez
prenons des procédures inhabituelles non
on se demande on se demande vraiment où
on est juste sur la motion de censure
Charles de Courson vous a dit oui pour
la porter c'est en discussion voilà de
poser lui la question à lui puisque je
vous dis pour l'instant on est en train
de travailler le scénario de voir si
nous avons des chances d'obtenir un vote
qui soit meilleur et de gagner cette
potion de censure mais je pense que
chaque jour chaque jour le pouvoir ne
tient plus qu'à un fil et le filet de
plus en plus petit et toute la nuque
vous êtes mis d'accord sur cette notion
de censure parce qu'il y a Olivier fort
nous disait que que la compétition
c'était que justement elle soit au moins
avoir égale par rapport à la précédente
c'est pourquoi nous en discutons voilà
c'est c'est mon collègue Eric Coquerel
qui a pris l'initiative qui est
président de la commission des finances
de proposer cette motion de censure on a
pris attaché avec les hôtes on discute
avec nos partenaires de la nups il y a
cette hypothèse de proposition de loi
proposée par le socialistes ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que sur le plan
institutionnel nous allons chercher
encore toutes les voies possibles et
imaginables pour faire reculer le
gouvernement mais vous le savez comme
moi ça va pas se jouer principalement là
ça va se jouer principalement dans le
rapport de force sociale que nous allons
avoir avec le gouvernement dans la rue
et le 1er mai fondamental tous les jours
aussi qui passent où il y a des
mobilisations vous savez que jeudi c'est
la colère cheminotte et enfin la
perspective politique parce que quand on
voit une telle crise de régime et je
vous parlais de 6e République il faut
bien travailler à l'alternative et donc
à la force politique que nous devons
construire à même de changer tout ça de
changer ce cap vous et ça c'est très
joli vous parlez pas du rythme vous n'y
croyez plus
écoutez vu la motivation
donnée par le Conseil constitutionnel
sur le refus du premier RIB j'avoue que
je suis très sceptique sur le second
mais un miracle est Civit arrivé on peut
toujours rêver d'un coup de théâtre et
c'est toujours possible donc oui
espérons que le Conseil constitutionnel
atterrisse lui et revient à la raison et
permettre cette sortie par le haut parce
que le rip c'est quand même sorti par le
haut en réalité le président de la
République même aurait dû dire annoncer
hier par exemple un référendum il aurait
calmé la situation il aurait calmé la
situation il décide de ne prendre aucune
issue qui permette d'apaiser le pays
tout en ayant ces mots apaisé unité
c'est pour ça qu'on a l'impression qu'il
se moque de nous qui nous fait des bras
d'honneur à chaque phrase parce que il
dit des mots qui sont des mots doux vous
voyez sucré et et pour en réalité ne
rien proposer de concret même sur
l'inflation c'est fou quand même c'est
le sujet majeur des Français et hier il
n'a pas un mot un mot pour tous les
Français qui le regardaient qui sont aux
abois exemple qui qui vous avez vu 42%
des Français les plus précaires ont
enlevé un repas par jour vous avez des
situations qui sont des situations
dramatiques dramatiques face à cette
hausse des prix notamment de
l'alimentation mais pas seulement parce
que c'est les prix de l'énergie du
carburant qui se répercutent sur
l'ensemble des loyers aussi qui se
répercutent sur l'ensemble et qui fait
que les gens sont sont à bout et que dit
le président de la République A1 on va
ouvrir des mais c'est tout tout est
il a parlé de l'augmentation des prix
qui passe sur la vie quotidienne
et le peu de proposition c'est cocasse
le peu de propositions un peu concrète
qu'il a qu'il a fait par exemple sur les
les l'augmentation de du nombre de
gendarmes vous savez que c'est dans la
loi
mais de qui mais qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette histoire de parler 13 minutes et
de raconter n'importe quoi mais quand tu
dis il m'apporte est ouverte aussi
notamment aux syndicats qui ont refusé
d'aller le rencontrer après avoir
demandé à ce que le président de la
République est les rencontres est-ce que
c'est pas là le la piste par laquelle il
y aura peut-être moyen de d'engager
quelque chose de nouveau mais si vous
n'y croyez pas très bien que le sujet
c'est l'abrogation de la réforme sur les
retraites il le sait donc il ouvre sa
porte mais sur un autre sujet et de
parler de de d'avoir un nouveau pacte de
vie au travail d'améliorer les
conditions de vie au travail de les
revenus des salariés
d'ailleurs on l'a vu sur le le partage
des temps c'est deux minutes les
retraites hop on passe à autre chose et
puis il reste 11 minutes sur le reste
mais sauf que ce qui comprend pas c'est
que si lui il veut tourner la page les
français eux n'ont pas décidé de tourner
la page et les syndicats non plus donc
il faut d'abord régler cette question
une fois qu'elle sera réglée on verra si
on est capable de discuter du reste mais
commençons par là parce que le reste
l'augmentation des revenus ça je pense
que ça ça intéresse beaucoup de gens
aussi mais évidemment un vrai sujet bien
sûr que c'est un vrai sujet mais
on reste au niveau du blocage ou alors
ou alors il a qu'à prendre des décisions
claires d'amélioration il peut
immédiatement veut dire j'augmente le
SMIC pourquoi ne l'a-t-il pas dit hier
il peut immédiatement dire je bloque les
prix des produits de première nécessité
la team fait hier non donc pour montrer
sa bonne foi s'il veut vraiment discuter
qu'il commence par prendre des mesures
qui sont des mesures attendues par la
majorité des Français qui seraient de
nature à faire en sorte que les
syndicats est avantage envie de prendre
le chemin de la négociation mais
aujourd'hui négocier avec avec quelqu'un
qui vous claque la portée en permanence
c'est pas possible leur Auberger a quand
même dit qu'il finirait par retourner à
la table des négociations pour parler de
ces sujets mais après le respect d'un
délai de décence il a raison bien sûr
évidemment que c'est impossible de
négocier tout de suite c'est lui moi je
suis pas à leur place et je ne parle au
début je sais pas moi qui vais dire
qu'elle est la conduite que de que doit
avoir un syndicat le prochain
rendez-vous pivot c'est le 1er mai en
fait c'est ça c'est la mobilisation
jusqu'au 1er mai je pense qu'il y a un
accord de tous les syndicats pour dire
que on ne parle pas autre chose que la
réforme des retraites c'est le sujet moi
j'appelle ici solanellement est-ce que
tous les Français utilisent ce 1er mai
pour faire prendre une voix par millions
et millions de Français de quelle
manière la France insoumise va porter
cette parole va prendre sa part à ce
premier mai d'abord on prend toujours
nos parts ça fait ce sera la 13e journée
de mobilisation c'est considérable en
réalité dans un contexte difficile pour
les Français parce que je pense que s'il
y avait pas ce problème de l'inflation
et des salaires qui sont des salaires
comprimés le pays aurait été bloqué
depuis belle lurette et donc il y a du
6D aussi de la part du pouvoir parce
qu'il le sait bien il le sait bien que
le niveau de colère est tel que
normalement le pays devrait être bloqué
et s'il ne l'est pas c'est parce que les
gens sont prêts à la gorge mais dans les
précédentes aujourd'hui vous étiez
plutôt en retrait par rapport aux
syndicat c'était un souhait des
politiques de laisser les syndicats en
première ligne on a appelé à manifester
on était présent dans les manifestations
dans les actions
spécifique on est on est moteur de la
mobilisation mais comme on l'a été
doucement et prendre sa part ça veut
dire appeler au 1er mai être actif et ça
nous allons le faire par tout un biais
de matériel militant et de prise de
parole publique pour inviter vraiment
tous les Français à s'approprier ce
premier mec qui doit être immense et qui
doit permettre de réveiller à Emmanuel
Macron je sais que la c'est difficile
j'entends bien mais c'est dire le nombre
de millions qu'il faut mettre dans la
rue pour que peut-être il arrive à
entendre ce qui se passe dans le pays
qui est censé gouverner sur la suite
parce qu'il a attendu là-bas pour la
suite il a parlé trois chantiers vous en
avez un peu parlé dont le premier celui
du travail il veut un nouveau pacte de
la vie au travail est-ce que vous êtes
prêt à travailler avec lui sur ce
chantier
mais je sais pas ce que ça veut dire en
fait travailler avec lui nous on est une
force politique on fait des propositions
sur le travail et Emmanuel Macron on
connaît son projet puisque ça fait 6 ans
qu'il l'applique et donc sur le travail
pour l'instant ce qu'il a fait
essentiellement c'est casser le code du
travail c'est
durcir les conditions de travail c'est
nous expliquer que il suffisait de
traverser la rue pour trouver un emploi
donc il y a du mépris sur le
comment dire la reconnaissance du
travail et en particulier du travail
pénible puisque lui-même avait dit quand
il était candidat je sais pas si vous en
souvenez mais il avait dit qu'il fallait
mieux reconnaître les métiers pénibles
et notamment tout cela la première ligne
qu'on avait tant salué au moment du
covid vous avez vu une augmentation vous
avez vu une mesure concrète rien
strictement rien il y a une mesure aussi
qu'il faudrait qu'il prenne augmenter le
salaire des fonctionnaires c'est pas
compliqué c'est de son ressort vous avez
un gel du point d'indice qui est
indécent vous avez une paupérisation
notamment des métiers les plus utiles on
le sait dans l'hôpital à l'école que
fait-il à rien strictement rien donc il
y a il y a un ras-le-bol aussi du
blablablables
mais quelle mesure les mesures les
mesures elles elles correspondent à une
certaine logique vous voyez c'est
sortir aussi les revenus du travail des
cotisations parce que par le biais des
primes par le biais de l'intéressement
vous les sortez des cotisations ça c'est
une logique très néolibérale très
néolibérale donc moi je suis pas
d'accord avec ça je suis je pense que ce
n'est pas cette ce qui est important
dans la
mais ce qui est important dans la
période actuelle il faut le comprendre
c'est de rééquilibrer le rapport entre
le capital et le travail voilà parce que
ça c'est détérioré et que vous le savez
mieux que moi le capital lui se porte
très bien et des revenus des dividendes
qui atteignent des des sommets des
sommets indécents 80 milliards d'euros
ont été redistribués en dividende
l'année dernière donc c'est bien ce
rapport entre capital travail qui ne va
pas et donc un gouvernement si nous nous
étions au pouvoir en tout cas nous
commencerions par faire en sorte qu'on
puisse mieux rémunérer le travail et en
particulier tous ceux qui ont des
métiers si utiles et qui sont si mal un
mot pour terminer sur le sur le sur la
Nupe Olivier Faure appelle un nouveau
souffle qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que oui
je suis d'accord avec vous êtes d'accord
bien sûr bien sûr et ça veut dire quoi
qu'est-ce que vous mettez derrière ce
terme pour moi il faut consolider la
nupcesse il faut la renforcer par le
haut et par le bas il faudrait que à
l'échelle du haut si j'ose dire on est
un mode de fonctionnement qui soit plus
fluide et qui permettent aussi
d'associer plus la sauce insoumise non
pourquoi ça pourquoi vous commencez
mutuellement par là non je pense que je
pense qu'il faut qu'on arrive à se
mettre d'accord sur un mode de
fonctionnement
vous arrivez à travailler ensemble
expressions publiques mais notez que à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a
tous les députés ont été élus dans le
cadre de la nupesse donc tous les
députés peut-être sont particulièrement
convaincus par l'intérêt de la nupestre
puisqu'on est passé 75 à 150 députés ce
qui est quand même un gros succès
alors plus fluide c'est quoi bah ça veut
dire ça veut dire par exemple créer une
structure nationale dans lequel on
puisse avoir du débat stratégique ça
veut dire que les instances qui sont les
instances exécutives on peut prendre des
initiatives au jour le jour soit
renforcées que tout le monde y participe
davantage et mieux et qu'on se comprenne
mieux sans hégémonie sans non plus
stratégie de faire de traîner les pieds
vous voyez bon tout ça
vous voyez bien moi j'ai pas envie non
mais j'ai pas envie de cotiser parce que
vous voyez en ce moment la nuit pêche on
a l'impression qu'il y en a un qui
mènera alors l'autre ajoute etc or s'il
y a une course à l'irresponsabilité on
n'a pas d'autre solution que la nuit
pèse donc ça je vous parlais du haut
mais je veux aussi parler du bas parce
que c'est important il faut qu'il y ait
des collectifs dans toute la France il
faut qu'on puisse être unis par des
projections des projections dans le
temps qui qui qui nous mettent en action
donc moi je pense par exemple que si on
était capable de faire des des assises
sur la démocratie la Sixième République
les libertés publiques dans tout le pays
et les mettre en mouvement avec la
nupaisse par exemple ce serait quelque
chose qui nous projetterait donc c'est
pas il y a une façon de voyez de trouver
les instances à la fois nationale et
locales qui nous permettent d'avancer ça
je pense qu'il faut le faire mais il
faut aussi le faire par la convergence
de ce que nous proposons dans le pays
donc il faut se mettre au travail il
faut se mettre au travail sur le projet
et les propositions concrètes on a fait
un programme en 13 jours très nuit à
l'évidence ne suffit pas donc il faut
continuer à travailler mais le plus
important c'est d'avoir cette volonté
politique si vous pensez que on peut se
passer de la nups que je crois être une
folie à ce moment là vous traînez les
pieds si vous savez que dans le cadre de
la tripolarisation soit on est unis et
une à une chance de gagner soit on est
divisé et c'est sûr qu'on a perdu
et bien normalement vous faites un petit
effort et vous vous dites qu'il faut
qu'on trouve des solutions et des
solutions pour ancrer pérenniser faire
entendre dans le pays le fait que nous
sommes l'alternative à la fin vous savez
c'est le rassemblement national ou c'est
nous et le nous il sera uni où il ne
sera pas parce que l'unité ne suffit pas
à gagner mais si vous êtes divisé alors
là franchement ça va être très très
compliqué de pouvoir prétendre gagner
notamment la prochaine élection
présidentielle et d'ici là on le sait il
y a les européennes il y a les
municipales donc il faut qu'on trouve à
chaque fois comment passer au mieux ses
échéances et moi je souhaite que nous
soyons à chaque étape le plus unis
possible merci Clémentine d'Autun merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
Stéphane la Une de Ouest-France et man
uel Macron tente de tourner la page
retraite merci beaucoup merci
clémentines merci